all right so what we're gonna do is um
you're gonna help me actually um because
this time the thing that is gonna um
help you see the reason why we're doing
this is that um
the working for each of these questions
even if they're simple
they all kind of share something in
common so let's see how we go what was
the first thing you wrote down before
the answer for your like working
oh i did like um five ten two
plus four times three
right so you kind of said oops here we
go it's these
denominators right so you wanted to get
a common denominator so you multiplied
by 5 over here so that gave you 10 on 15
and
12 on 15. so then once you've got that
you're like oh there's not much more to
do is there did you leave it as uh an
improper fraction or did you change it
to a mixed number
yeah sure so i was like i'm fine with
that they didn't ask me to have it this
way or the other
so that's all good fantastic now this
one here
i think remember i asked you to simplify
it what did you do to help simplify it
uh-huh and what do you get i got x plus
2 and then x plus 3. yep
wonderful okay and then you're like oh
great i can actually just cancel because
this is on the denominator and the
numerator so then you just get a very
simple answer which is
x plus 2. by the way very few students
notice this and it's a kind of nitpicky
thing but it's might as well mention it
right
this thing here and this thing here they
look almost identical because you've
cancelled right but actually do you know
how when you've got something on the
denominator
the denominator is never allowed to be
zero right you remember that like
because you can't divide by zero the
universe explodes all that kind of thing
um and this is what we call a domain
restriction that x
in this case it can't equal to
uh
negative three yeah yeah exactly because
if you put negative three in that would
make the whole thing zero right and
these kinds of domain restrictions they
happen all the time even this question
here didn't talk about it but that's got
a domain restriction too right x can't
be
a negative number because then um
you can't take the square over negative
right at least under our rules so
therefore i just want to point out that
this actually kind of has like this
thing sort of hidden on the side right
you don't normally need to write it but
it's worth just remembering
okay for this next one here what did you
do with this we actually did this a few
days ago
yeah fantastic so what you did was you
said it's weird as a square root but if
you change it into an index
well actually can i ask you why is that
better like usually we would prefer to
write things like this what's the
advantage here
i don't know
yeah yeah it is absolutely like that's
the thing you're being asked to do
and because it's something raised to a
power you're like oh i have a i have a
rule for that right so i'm going to
bring the power at the front
and then what's the next step you do
x
to the power
whatever two minus one yeah exactly so
we'll subtract one from that which i
guess would be negative a half
strictly speaking that's the answer but
we could probably tidy it up a little
bit did you go further than this or
just left it like that let's just do
just for the sake of it what would the
next step be like that negative what
does that mean
do you know when you've got a negative
power
yeah that's right it's actually division
right so for example uh oh do a better
way of writing it
beside if i said to you 2 cubed right
that means
multiply it 3 times two times two times
two but if i gave you to the negative
three that actually means divide three
times it's the opposite yeah so this
negative means divide so it's actually
the two will be on the denominator
and the x to the half will be on the
denominator so i would write that as two
root x down there is that okay really
but yeah like that's fine that's okay
all right now last one now you got an
answer for this so can you just tell me
what you did like did you have a line of
work after this or did you go straight
to your calculator
okay which is fine because from memory i
actually checked i think you got the
right answer what did you get x equals
one point
cool and of course you can actually uh
dot dot dot well i think i asked for
three
decimal places did not yeah so i can
just put that there
you can actually check because you've
got a calculator there right and we
would need a calculator to handle this
you could just put this in and see if it
works
10 to the power of
1.602 now because we've rounded
i'm guessing it'll be like 39 something
or other yeah sure the way you could
know it though and i'm guessing this is
how you did it
is this is an exponential equation we
can rewrite it as
x
equals
now
to turn it into a log equation here's
the way i remember it
the base that you have oh i chose a
really bad red marker the base that you
have here it becomes the new base in
your log equation so
you get base 10
of 40 and that should go straight is
that what you punched into your
calculator or did you do something else
divided by 110 oh yeah okay so that also
uh another color
that also works so this is what we call
the um
the change of bass
rule because you can have any number
there you like two or five or et cetera
i actually chose 10 to try and let you
be lazy because there's a base 10 button
on your calculator yeah do you see that
um
let me just have a quick look
it'll be just that one right there so if
we went log
40. press equals for me
bam there you go so um and by the way
the reason why
uh your calculator has two bases on it
for logs it's got ten and do you know
what the other one is
it's e
do you remember e is that funny number
right it's like um
it's something like 2.718
and extra stuff right so um
mathematicians care a lot about this
number
scientists care about this number
because it's scientific notation right
if we're like oh how big is the mass of
the earth it's like
6.7 times 10 to the whatever so that 10
is what they're talking about
okay
so you can sort of rule that off um and
underneath that i want to make a little
subheading for me which is
um
exponential functions
i might just abbreviate because i'm
slightly lazy
with now
i'm gonna leave there's gonna be a
couple of words that i put in here and i
just wanna i'll tell you what they are
in a second
um
the reason why i highlighted this guy
here is because we actually over the
last few lessons we've been
differentiating a lot of exponential
functions and they all kind of shared
this thing in common so there's like
e to the x
or e to the like i don't know 3x plus 1
or some other version of this like maybe
it was like one over e to the x plus
four it didn't matter you saw this e
happening over and over again
and that's because you probably remember
that when you differentiate e to the x
it's like this really nice lazy result
right what do you get
yeah exactly you're like cool i didn't
do anything right
now that's all well and good
but then the challenge comes when you
say well hold on a second
not all exponential functions
have e
as a base for example like i can put any
number that i like there so the question
becomes
how do i deal with it when it has
another
base
right
now here's where we come to these these
particular questions and why i gave them
to you even though they might seem very
simple okay
for the first three questions even
though one looks like a fraction
question one looks like an algebra
question and one looks like a
differentiation question you actually
did the same thing
three different ways to solve each
question here's what i mean
when you add these two together
you sort of instinctively said oh i
should get common denominators why is
that
why like why do you do that for
to um
yeah because you're like i i need them
to kind of be talking the same language
and then you just put them together
right
now you rewrote them as common
denominators and then it was fine have a
look at question two again i didn't tell
you to factorize
you kind of knew to factorize though
right why is that
do you even see
like
yeah like i'm looking for when i've got
things to cancel the things i cancel are
common factors so like if i can find a
common factor then sweet right um so
this is really interesting when i told
you to simplify this question sometimes
the factorized form is better sometimes
the expand formula just depends what
you're doing right
so in other words you wrote this
fraction just in a different way same
fraction dressed up in different clothes
and then it was easy to get an answer
and then this is the last one here now
you did exactly the same thing
i gave it to you in a square root
and you instinctively changed it into
index form because then you could treat
it like
a problem you've done before right
so in each question you basically
dressed it up differently and you were
good to go as soon as you like
this is the same as this and this is the
same as this but it's in an easier
format